we're on question 95 a certain
salesperson weekly salaries equal to a
fixed base salary plus a commission that
is directly proportional to the number
of items sold during the week I mean
right there 95 so the salary is equal to
some base plus plus a commission that is
directly proportional to the number of
items sold during the week so let's say
the items number of items sold is X X
items x I don't know the Commission per
item so I'll call that lower case C and
this is a total Commission fair enough
Commission hey if 50 items are sold this
week what will be the sales salesperson
salary for this week okay so they
actually told us that there's 50 items
fair enough what will be the salesperson
salary this week so statement number one
tells us last week 45 items were sold so
45 in last week that alone doesn't tell
me much right because I don't know how
much he made last week statement to last
week's salary was four hundred five
dollars four hundred and five dollars
well does this help me still last week
because in order to figure out what we
need to figure out right now we need to
know how much of his salary in any given
week is base and how much Commission
does he get per unit right and the only
way we could figure that out is if you
tell us the last week we know that he
sold 45 items so for example last week
he made four hundred five dollars if I
use both statements let me see if I can
get any where he made four hundred five
dollars last week which is equal to his
base plus forty five units sold times
his Commission per unit so that's all
this information gives me if actually if
I use both statements that's all it
gives me
right the 405 is equal to B plus 45
times C and we need to figure out s is
equal to B plus 50 C right what is s
equal when when when you sell 50 units
and so we have two linear equations but
we have how many unknowns we have one
unknown two unknown three unknowns sorry
one unknown two unknown three unknowns
right B and C was already there so we
have three unknowns but only two linear
equations so we don't have enough
information to solve it so the answer is
what is that e we all ball of these
statements still do not give us enough
information 96 96 if one had a doctor's
appointment on a certain day was the
appointment on a Wednesday so we want to
know was it on a Wednesday one exactly
60 hours before the appointment it was
Monday
60 hours before the appointment it was
Monday 60 hours before it was Monday
this is interesting okay so how many at
60 hours is two days two days is 48
hours two days it's exactly two and a
half days right 48 and then another 12
so this is equal to two and a half days
two and a half days before so this is
interesting if we said if you said that
two days before it was a Monday then his
appointment had to have been on a
Wednesday right because if you pick if
you pick any hour and Wednesday and you
go exactly 48 hours ago it would be that
same exact hour on Monday right so if
you said 48 hours ago it was Monday then
you then this would be enough
information this is two and a half days
ago so for example if his appointment
and you know it might sound weird but if
his appointment was at let's say
Thursday Thursday 1:00 a.m.
and you got two and a half days before
let's see if you go two days ago before
you go to Wednesday 1 a.m. Tuesday 1
a.m. and then you go 12 hours before you
would end up at Monday at 1:00 p.m.
Monday at 1:00 p.m. so I've given a case
that meets condition 1 where his
appointment wasn't on Wednesday it was
on Thursday but of course I can give a
condition where his appointment was on
Wednesday if his point was on Wednesday
at 10:00 p.m. then if you go one day
back you at Tuesday 10 p.m. I don't know
I'm sure you can't read that then you go
another day you're at Monday 10 p.m. and
then you go half a day you're at Monday
10 a.m. so statement 1 does not give us
enough information it's because of this
pesky half day now let's see what
statement to get us for us
statement 2 the appointment was between
1:00 p.m. and 9:00 p.m.
1:00 p.m. to 9:00 p.m. now this by
itself obviously is useless I mean you
could have an appointment any day
between 1:00 p.m. and 9:00 p.m. but used
in conjunction with each other it seems
like I have enough information because
let's say the appointment was at 9:00
p.m. and 2 days two and a half days ago
it was a Wednesday so let me see you
9:00 p.m.
sorry two days ago it was a Monday so if
I have it at Wednesday 9:00 p.m. if I go
back one day I'm at Tuesday 9:00 p.m.
Tuesday I met sorry one day back I'm at
Tuesday 9:00 p.m. two days back I'm at
Monday 9:00 p.m. and then if I go half a
day more I'm at Monday 9:00 a.m. right
and if I take the lower bound Wednesday
at 1:00 p.m. do the same logic and
you're going to end up at Monday 1:00
a.m. so at either end of this range if I
know that if you go two days ago you end
up with Monday the only day that works
is Wednesday you could try this with
Thursday or Tuesday you won't end up
Monday if you go two and a half days
back so for this problem both statements
are necessary in order to know whether
his appointment was on Wednesday next
problem 97 what is the value of 5x
squared plus 4x minus 1 first they tell
us x times X plus 2 is equal to 0 well
let's see can we use this alone let's
multiply it out we get x squared plus 4x
is equal to 0 and that tells us that x
squared is equal to minus 4x well maybe
we could substitute this in for 4x so or
4x squared so we get 5 times x squared
well we know that x squared is minus 4x
minus 4x plus 4x minus 1 that's that's
minus 20x plus 4x minus 1 oh doesn't get
us anywhere even playing around with the
algebra so we get minus 16x minus 1 so a
statement by statement 1 by itself at
least as far as I can figure out does
not help us solve this problem statement
number two statement number two X is
equal to zero well that's all we need X
is equal to 0 then this is 0 this is 0
and we're just left with negative 1 so
this is the only piece of information we
need to solve this problem and statement
1 doesn't really help us much so only
statement 2 is necessary what is that B
next problem 99 98 98 at Larry's auto
supply store Brand X antifreeze is sold
by the gallon so X by gallon and brand Y
sold by the court Y by the quart
excluding sales tax
what is the total cost for one gallon of
Brand X antifreeze so 1 of X 1 of X and
one quart of blant Brent brand y okay so
we want to know the cost equals how much
dollars so let X be the number of
gallons of x and y be the number of
quarts of y so we'd have to know we'd
have to know their prices in order to
figure out how much does the combination
cost so let's see at least I think
statement 1 excluding sales tax the cost
for 6 gallons of Brand X antifreeze so 6
gallons of Brand X antifreeze and 10
quarts of Y so plus 10 of y is equal to
$58 well this once again by itself does
not help me much I have to eat 2
unknowns with one linear equation so I
can't solve for what X plus y is equal
to I mean there's if I could have
factored out if this was 10 X + 10 Y I
could have factored out of 10 and I
would have had X plus y right sitting
there so I should I probably could have
solved if it was that way but this isn't
quite as easy so statement number two
excluding sales tax the total cost for 4
gallons of Brand X for gallons of Brand
X plus 12 quarts of Brand y plus 12
quarts of brand y is equal to $44 and
actually just to be exact I've I realize
I misspoke something let X let X be the
cost X equals the cost of X antifreeze
per gallon and Y is equal to the cost of
y antifreeze for gallon and so we want
one so we are still trying to figure out
X plus y but I just wanted to be exact
because we got 6 gallons so the cost
would be 6 times X plus 10 quarts of y
so it would be 10 times y to get 58 etc
etc but now we have two equations with 2
so it's trivial now to solve for x and y
this is your algebra 1 problem so both
equations combined are enough to solve
for it but each independently are not
enough because you can't just factor out
a number and just be left with X plus y
here that could have been a trick if
this was a tricky problem but it's not
anyway see you in the next video